[Music]
hello everyone and welcome back to the
road 2000. as always my name is kill
denby and i am still your driver on this
journey
um what i want to talk about tonight is
of course the historic game six of the
ongoing world championship match uh as
of today magnus leads with a three-game
advantage after a couple bad blunders by
yon
but as of game six the players were
deadlocked in a tie so this was the game
that uh seemingly started
yawn's big downfall it was the longest
chess game ever played in a world
championship match at least by move
count uh and by time it was pretty long
as well lasting i i think about eight
hours uh at least that's how long the
broadcasts were
so kind of a crazy long game and it's
obviously been covered a lot on
youtube but what i wanted to do is take
a look at it through a slightly
different lens so
um i've personally been enjoying the
commentary by peter svidler vlad kramnik
and
miro on a channel that i don't think too
many people know about so it's called
levitate chess world if you haven't
heard of that and like those
commentators i would recommend checking
it out
and something i loved about their
commentary is they brought up a bunch of
games that the position was reminding
them of and so what i wanted to do is
take a look at some historical games and
see how knowledge of those games might
influence the decisions of the players
and how you can use knowledge of past
games to influence your own decisions in
your own games but to start with let's
take a look at the opening in the game
here
magnus chose a slightly unusual move
order uh in the catalan
so of course normal would be to start
with the pawn on c4 immediately
challenging the center
instead uh magnus opts to just play
knight f3 and g3 so committing to uh
theon kettling this bishop but not yet
pressuring the pawn on d5
now the the small little nuance here is
there's a reason this isn't a popular
move order and one of those big reasons
is it allows black to potentially
develop this light squared bishop and
get a quality just a little bit easier
whereas if we play something like c4
bishop f5 is going to be a lot harder to
attain because we have this immediate
pressure on the center uh pressure
that's normally relieved by c6 or e6 so
that's why g3 is a little bit less
common but g3 is magnus carlsen's choice
and that's probably because he was
hoping to get nepo out of his direct
preparation obviously jan is going to be
familiar with the opening in general and
familiar with the positions arising
but perhaps you won't have the exact
moves at least memorized
and to that effect magnus was somewhat
successful yan plays e6 pretty quickly
both players develop we get castles
castles and then uh here magnus again
has the opportunity to transpose to the
main line with c4 but instead he opts
for this uh little uh nuance here with
the move pawn to b3
and so with this i think yan was taken
more or less out of his direct
preparation obviously he's going to be
very familiar with the position but uh
magnus has in a sense succeeded in
getting on to play you know
think by his own brain as komarov would
say rather than the engine at home
we saw this move c5 come out pretty
quickly
d take c5 was magnus's choice and then
this moves c4
after a little bit of thought yan takes
on c4 sort of demonstrating that this
was the first move he was playing
entirely on his on his own
uh magnus has this nice little nuance of
queen to c2 here
and i just want to mention that this
move dtake c4 was getting a little bit
of criticism from a lot of the
commentary teams
and perhaps it's indicative of jan's
slightly less uh
experience in the position slightly
lesser experience
he's at heart a grunfeld player and so
positions like these he hasn't played
quite as much in his career
and for example it might make sense to
develop the pieces a little bit
a little bit more before opening up this
diagonal because capturing immediately
does give white some tactical
opportunities for example we see the
move queen to c2
and rather than having to immediately
recapture
white is taking advantage of the
slightly loose bishop the lack of
development from black to
uh take back the pawn a little bit more
favorably
black doesn't panic though yawn just
plays queen to e7 and now we get this
move knight b to d2 so this of course
is a pawn sacrifice so what what's going
on here
well yan essentially could capture on b3
white would likely take back with the
knight
we would see something like bishop to d6
and then white really does have a
variety of options here you can do any
number of things maybe the the retreat
with knight f to d2 is something that
magnus had planned it looks a little bit
weird but it really takes advantage of
the fact that black is undeveloped on
the queen's side basically white just
wants to activate this bishop as quickly
as possible and make developing these
queen side pieces a little bit more
difficult for for black
so perhaps seeing some of these lines
jan wasn't thrilled with the idea of
capturing on b3
and having to defend a position uh with
an extra pawn
psychologically that can be pretty tough
right you're just on the back foot right
from the opening and yawn didn't didn't
see the need for that
so instead yan finds this nice idea of
knight to c6 and after knight takes c4
um i would be a little bit worried with
the black pieces here actually if not
for this nice resource that yan had
found so
let's say you just played a normal
looking move like rook to d8
what do you guys think would be going on
here what would white be be aiming to
to play
why does black have a little bit of
cause for concern
you have those three pieces lined up
along the black diagonal is that a cause
for concern or not
uh the diagonal or the
the with the the knife the queen and the
not the other one oh this way okay um
yeah that's not going to be be the
biggest problem here um we'll actually
see that this diagonal comes into play a
little bit later and it's definitely an
important feature
but what i'm getting at is
if you give white too much time here as
we saw in the pawn sacrifice line it's
going to be really difficult for black
to finish development
like let's say something like knight to
knight f to e5 for example already
opening up this bishop and just just to
play some moves here you're not saying
these are the best let's say black tries
capturing and we capture back
uh all of a sudden it's gonna be really
really difficult to
deal with all of this pressure to the
queenside pawns it's the quote-unquote
catalan bishop
super strong bishop on the wide open
diagonal that's going to apply a lot of
pressure on on black's queen's side
so there is sort of a sense of urgency
here for black because if you don't
finish your development now you may not
get a chance to
or if you do white's already going to be
lined up on these open files before you
have a chance to contest them right you
can't really take your time here and you
often have to to sort of rush things in
against the catalan because given enough
time
white can organize the pieces to put a
lot of pressure on those light squares
so that's why yon went for this really
interesting idea of b5 so this might be
counterintuitive right we were just
saying that black's problems lie on this
long open diagonal and seemingly playing
the pawn out to b5 only serves to help
weaken these squares right like now this
knight has no defender it's opposite
this bishop and the bishop also has
access to the rook on a8
so what did jan have in mind
well it's actually a very very forcing
line everything is is coming with tempo
and he just calculated out that uh white
doesn't have a chance to make use of the
weak diagonal uh before black can
actually contest it so this is going to
be a common idea for black to equalize
in
against the catalan basically blacks is
saying that he can get his bishop out to
b7 and contest this bishop on g2 with
his own bishop uh before anything bad
happens so
b5 happens with tempo so magnus brings
the knight out to e5
and then again another tempo move knight
to b4 is crucial to black getting full
equality here so knight to b4 hits this
queen on c2
magnus takes uh advantage of this square
he opened up on b2 with the move b3 and
now we see this move bishop to b7 and
here jan is saying okay i finished my
development
um it didn't happen for free this move
pawn to b5 is maybe a little bit further
than jan would have liked to go with his
b-pawn we can see that it weakened some
squares that's going to come up in a
little bit
but more or less yan should have
achieved
equality after bishop to b7 he negated
this pressure on the long diagonal and
is doing well so far
uh now we see this move a3 by magnus
it's very very sensible he just wants to
take back his b4 square
and here jan chooses the move knight to
c6 over something like knight to d5 i
think knight to d5 is also pretty
acceptable
uh and from here
after knight to c6
magnus plays a nice little move knight
to d3 and this move in combination with
magnus's next move uh are going to lead
me to my first historical game that that
i want to bring up so
1993 to start with is keeping a knight
on the board keeping some pieces on the
board and we'll see why in just a moment
bishop to b6 and then magnus plays this
move bishop to g5 so
let's try and understand why magnus
plays the move bishop to g5
and what magnus might have been thinking
over the next few moves so does anybody
know
what magnus might be aiming for here
it's okay if you don't because at the
time when i was watching the game i
didn't didn't fully understand either
so let's state the obvious first so
magnus is pinning the knight to the
queen putting some pressure on this
piece
and the question is why
you know why do this
and to give you one more move yan for
example played rook f to d8 in response
very simple improving move
i'm willing to bet if you haven't seen
the game or if you've forgotten magnus's
next move might surprise you just a
little bit
any areas
there's nothing earth shattering here
but just good chess moves what comes to
mind what seems
natural i i think what seems natural is
i mean thinking about
bishop takes f6 and then um
and then whether
whether the queen takes or not we double
those pawns and maybe
you know you know i'm a better pawn
structure at least yeah okay so this is
well then you're not surprised by
magnus's next move because magnus
actually does immediately capture on f6
now this move i would actually say is
just a little bit unnatural and the
reason for that
is in general when you have a piece sort
of really pinned down
uh it makes sense to leave it there
right the the piece isn't going to walk
away it can't move it's pins and so it
seems like the idea of bishop takes f6
isn't going anywhere so why rush things
by by capturing the knight that's why i
would sort of characterize it as
surprising
other natural moves might just be
bringing a rook to the center something
like this and those seem totally fine
and acceptable as as well
but
what magnus is going for is actually
something pretty specific so let's see
what happens after we take on f6 so we
take on f6 yawn actually does take back
with uh
the pawn
and the reason for that is i think yan
wanted to go for some pretty quick
simplifications and we can see those
happen after it to c1 and knight to d4
and this actually wouldn't quite be
possible if yon had traded the queens so
for example queen f6 if we take take and
go down the exact same line
knight d4 actually has a tactical
problem here
and the problem is we can take
and now unlike in the game
the bishop on b7 is actually hanging
there's no queen on e7 to defend it
anymore and so you cannot take on d4 you
have to take on g2 and white has some
nice ideas here like knight takes e6
these intermediate moves uh taking
advantage of the placement of
blackstrokes
and for example if you're not convinced
by that line let's let's bring the other
rook to c1 and then it's even more
apparent because here
you simply have to move the rook there's
no bishop takes f1 tricks and uh clearly
this simplification idea by yan is is
not going to be working so
i think that's why jan ended up taking
with the pawn just again more
calculation
and then magnus brings the rook to the c
file we get knight d4 takes takes on d4
again this is possible because of the
queen
queen to a2 slightly awkward move by
magnus but he needed to keep this a3
upon defended
uh and then takes on g2 takes on g2
so the question is what's going on in
this position why was magnus aiming for
this
and i think it might be difficult to
understand you know why why would magnus
want to aim for a position like this
when it seems like black has a very
active bishop and should be doing doing
fine objectively and objectively black
is doing doing fine
but to understand why magnus went for
this i actually want to go to a game
between
zoltan ribley and anatoly karpov from a
while back now
if you haven't heard of ribley i think
he's uh one of the very very strong
hungarian players that have uh been
there kind of throughout history always
lurking in the top 10 somewhere
and of course anatoly karpov is anatoly
karpov
so what happened in this game in this
game we see sort of a similar catalan
position uh the difference here is that
the knight has been traded for the dark
squared bishop on f4 and it's actually
white with the fractured pawns rather
than black
and what happened quickly in this game
is after c5 we saw these pieces come off
the board the queens also got traded
here
we saw a couple more moves and then
after knight e5 takes takes
and this
uh
material balance should seem pretty
familiar to our game we have a knight
versus the bishop and a couple of rooks
on the board
and i think it's because of positions
like this and magnus's experience in the
catalan
i think this is why he chose to go down
this path
where he was sort of aiming for this
balance of pieces because it turns out
although objectively black is doing okay
in this position i mean the material's
even the pawns are almost symmetric we
have four versus four and two versus two
despite all of this it turns out that
this knight is going to be really really
useful compared to the bishop and indeed
in the game we saw this knight get
driven away
white shores up the pawns and then white
was able to target these various
weaknesses in the black camp now in this
case it's the e6 pawn that's weak when
that's not going to be the case in
magnus's game but black doesn't indeed
have weaknesses in that position as well
and despite the the even looking
position here uh white very convincingly
uh improves his position targets the
weaknesses
and before too long is able to use this
strong knight as a nice attacking piece
along with the rook
and white wins this game pretty pretty
convincingly here we see
three versus two on the king's side
the rook cleans up another pawn
and then without getting into too much
detail um there's a lot of back and
forth here not the most well played end
game in the world
but white does indeed win this uh this
rook end game in the end with
resignation happening
not there but here because if you move
the rook
that's actually checkmate
um and so knowledge of games like this
where you
have been exposed to these ideas before
you've seen that this balance of pieces
tends to be good for white practically
the knight is going to be more useful
than the bishop it's going to have good
squares good outposts
and is going to give you a good end game
to try and press a little bit having
knowledge of games like this in the
openings that you play
is really going to help you in your
decision making because magnus is
familiar with positions like this maybe
not necessarily even this exact game but
this idea this end game because of all
of that he's able to more confidently
maneuver the game towards that material
and balance keeping in mind that this
knight's going to be useful to target
all these weaknesses lurking in in the
black camp
and he's so confident in that material
balance that he's even willing to allow
black
to get very very active in this case so
what jan is essentially going for here
is he is
uh saying my pieces are so active in the
center of the board that you know your
positional understanding your knowledge
of this end game it's it's not really
going to make a difference here you have
to deal with my active active pieces and
you're not going to be able to maneuver
the game
uh to that better ending that you're
hoping for
uh but i just want to highlight you know
if you don't know these things about the
position magnus's plan here
kind of seems a little bit like strange
you know it just seems like magnus is
randomly trying to trade pieces and get
a draw when i think that does sell it a
little bit short
he's on purpose trading very specific
pieces aiming to leave black with this
dark squared bishop against the strong
knight on d3
so does that make sense like any
questions about how we're making that
that jump
yeah
yeah i'm sorry if i missed this but it
was the same opening right yeah it was
also a catalan in the ribley karpov
game um i didn't show the full opening
but uh it was a similar catalan where
again and rather than trading the bishop
for the knight on f6 the trade happened
with the knight capturing on on f4 so
yeah so if you're
preparing to play the catalan this
you would like go through games like
this
yeah exactly um and that that's the the
point to take away you know obviously
not everybody here is going to be a
catalan player
but by looking at historical games and
famous games and the openings that you
play that's how you can start to build
up your knowledge and feel a lot more
confident in your decisions you can more
confidently trade off these pieces when
you know that this should be a good
endgame for white this should be a
comfortable end game for white if you've
never seen that game and never seen that
idea it's going to be really really
tough um to just sort of decide that on
the spot at the chessboard that you
think this is a good end game you know
it's it's not very clear at the moment
that this knight should be better than
this bishop but because we've seen these
games happen before we know how how it
works out practically
magnus is able to make those decisions
and i really highlight that in this case
because i think that's where jan has
been lacking in this world championship
he's sort of changed his style to fit
the world championship he's no longer
the grunfeld attacking yon napomnishi
that we know instead he's sort of
adopting the fabiano caruana style of
play where he's super solid tries to
play all the best moves and the
downslide of that
is he doesn't quite have as much
experience as a player like magnus
carlson in these positions of course
he's miles miles better than anybody in
this room but that that's my take on it
uh but in the game we still have a lot
of chess left to cover we're only on
move 20 of like 100
billion 100 billion moves in this game
um we get queen e4 activating the queen
magnus brings the queen back to life
from its little hole on a2 we see this
move a5 it's a pretty nice move by by
yan it's a good improving move
threatening things like a4 things like
b4 to
uh
force white to give up control of some
squares on the queen side
we see the move rook after d1
and then a slightly uh timid move king
g7
by
black and then here
yeah sorry go ahead
what was the thought
um so it's actually a move that jan
played very very quickly in just a
minute and a half
and it's just a
typical improving move right by bringing
the king to g7 you get the king off of
the eighth rank where it might get
checked you help to defend your weakness
on f6
and uh it it supposedly is going to
improve the king's position in this case
i do think it's actually a little bit of
a mistake because it doesn't improve
your position that much
and indeed you might actually be
stepping into potential checks a little
bit later on so i'm not in love with the
move king g7 i think it was maybe a
little bit rushed by jan in this case
but that's the idea the king should in
theory stand better on g7 than on g8 it
just helps defend your weak squares
because the g7 pawn is is missing
but yeah that being said i'm not not in
love with this move
uh i'm also not in love with magnus
carlson's response so he played this
move rook to d2
now does anybody remember or
no
what white is is trying to go for here
if you've seen the game uh you you might
have some idea of what magnus had in
mind but
how is magnus dealing with these super
strong centrally placed pieces
how is he trying to deal with them
because it's great to talk about having
the the theoretically better end game
but if your opponent has super active
pieces
you're going to be in for a little bit
of trouble
it looks like he's doing everything he
can to
not
push his pawns
i think the commentators are really
shocked that uh e3 wasn't played right
so e3 is essentially the the idea and i
think it's the best move in this case
um and that has to eventually be your
idea to deal with the pressure of this
bishop against the king's side and move
it to a slightly worse square
so what magnus did in the game rook d2
is a slower version of actually the same
plane i think his idea was the same
but i think e3 immediately was was
definitely called for so let's say rook
d2 and i mean let's let's
say black passes here something like h6
you know just just to put a move on the
board
um i think what magnus might have been
intending is to go queen to d1 and
follow this with the move e3 so allowing
this queen to have access to the king's
side to attack some of those weak
squares
with the idea of the eventual e3 however
i think this idea was a little bit too
slow i think instead like you were
saying that the commentators thought
this as well the immediate e3 was was
definitely the way to go just for
example the bishop moves out of the way
we can bring the queen to e2
and black actually has to walk a pretty
thin line here to maintain equality
i think what black needs to do is
actually play this move h5
trying to create some threats
of checkmate or just at least opening up
the white king white might play h4 in
response and then black has a few moves
but keeping an eye on these pawns is a
good idea something like knight c5 and
we might see some simplifications here
although again an endgame like this is
exactly what magnus carlsen kind of had
in mind you know you get to this knight
and rook end game against bishop and
rook and already there are very concrete
problems like knight to b7 that jan
would have had to deal with just in this
example line black should still be fine
but practically i think this is what
magnus wanted he wanted an end game like
this where you can play for a long long
time try and uh
provoke some some mistakes from yan and
sneak his way to a victory now we don't
actually see that happen in the game but
i think e3 immediately was definitely
called for by magnus and yeah what's up
brian
oh
uh
mind i was about to say was he thinking
about one of the rooks to see eight and
then in that case he'd want to
um tuck his queen behind the rope um
well it's it's interesting that you say
that because rookie to see it was played
in the game um but going to e2 also
um
if he had played e3 first yeah and we'll
see that magnus had no intention of
moving the queen out of the way against
rigata
c8 um
but yeah
of course uh after e3 uh i'm not
entirely sure what's going on after rook
a to c8
um
this involves more calculation than
i might be able to do but i think maybe
knight c5 is working
uh take take
and you have some problems right
uh take here i guess
and then
now if you take there then i can take
back
so bishop takes
takes takes takes
although maybe this end game is is gonna
be a draw so
all right let me ask the the engine
overlords here what's going on okay
again you just take on c8 and you get to
uh to positions we are more familiar
with as as happened in the game
um okay
but instead of e3 we see rook to d2 by
magnus and now as i just said rook a to
c8 was jan's choice in the game but
we'll see that this ends up being a a
little bit risky actually this imbalance
of the two rooks versus the queen uh
tends to favor the two rooks if they can
get coordinated
and so by playing rook a to c8 and
allowing
magnus to capture
jan is really now relying on the
activity of his pieces it's sort of a
dynamic versus static advantage that you
might have heard of before
black has the dynamic advantage because
the rooks are discoordinated and black
has active pieces with which to kind of
attack
but statically the position should favor
white the two rooks tend to be better
than the queen
and of course black structure also uh
allows white to to attack some
weaknesses
so by playing arcade to c8
yan really commits himself to finding
solutions to these problems
in the near future because given enough
time magnus will organize the pieces and
this will attack the weaknesses and win
the game
so rook a2c8 is definitely not without
risk this is a very risky move by yan
and that's why i think e3 might have
been a better better idea because if
rookie to see it is the best that yan
has against e3 then we should be happy
as white you know with our opponent
taking on a little bit of risk here
now after rook to d2 i think the why
this is a bad move is because
black does have a a very convincing way
to
get a quality without risking quite as
much so
uh we've talked about how the end game
tends to not be
great for black but black has a nice
resource here to sort of permanently
ensure his bishop is going to be a
fantastic piece
so i'll give you a moment to think about
it see if you can come up with with any
ideas
and and great wolf in the chat is
jumping a little bit ahead of me
uh this bishop takes e3 stuff is going
to come up like 60 moves later
like i said it's it's a long game
there's a lot to talk about
um
yeah f5 is is a pretty thematic move um
giving this bishop a square but also
very very importantly introducing ideas
of of f4 when you have the queen against
the two rooks or just in general um
and i know we don't have the queen
against the two rooks just yet but it's
really important that the queen is able
to make threats against the enemy king
these checking opportunities are what
allow the queen to kind of keep the
balance so f5 would be good
but it's actually
more direct than that it's more
permanent than that it's turning
black's dynamic advantage the active
pieces into
a more permanent advantage to make sure
he doesn't have anything to worry about
in the end game
which okay now i've given so many hints
that
the
your your thoughts might be a little bit
clouded uh the move b4 is the one that i
think yon should have gone for
uh and the idea is that if you think
you're gonna win a pawn
uh not so lucky not you're not quite
that fortunate and black is is doing
okay here the king is now weak the pawns
are fractured yes white has this past
pawn but it's not going very far
of course white doesn't have to fall for
this trick and can play something like
e3 as sort of planned but now the idea
is we're going to cement our bishop on
this really nice square of c3 and this
is the more permanent um
advantage that i was talking about not
that black is better but black has a
very very strong bishop so it doesn't
really matter that our knight should in
theory be better because jan very
directly has this amazing bishop on c3
hampering all of white's major pieces
and black should just be totally totally
equal here in my opinion
so i like this idea of b4 instead rook a
to c8 but this does come with some risks
so white does capture
and we get this move queen to d5 so
jan has the right idea he has very
active pieces he needs to do something
with them before white can get
coordinated so targeting this pawn on b3
we now get pawn to b4 by white
a4 by black and now yan is is hoping to
take advantage of the weak a3 pawn and
if he can do so uh successfully then he
should be able to to draw the game
uh okay in the game we get e3 by white
this is always eventually going to be
the plan the bishop steps back to e5 and
h4 by white is a nice improving move
it's nice to have two options for this
king so we don't ever get perpetualed or
checked annoyingly by the queen on this
diagonal
and
this pawn is actually going to be used
in another really important theme in the
position
uh now yan plays a very controversial
move h5 um the lead chess board gives it
question mark exclamation point i'm
going to turn those off i hate those
annotations but
why is this move controversial well
i believe jan played this move because
black does have reasons to be concerned
about this pawn having more mobility and
the reason is
black's king is actually going to be
really relevant in this endgame
if white can organize the rooks to come
and attack the black king there's very
serious chances of just checkmate
occurring
and this is going to be an excellent
segue into another historical game to
look at i'm actually going to look at
two historical games to give you some
idea of what's going on in this end game
how do these players have any idea
what's going on well the answer is
they're familiar with chess history
so i first want to turn your attention
to
another world championship game
uh does anybody remember the lekko
kramnik match
i was barely alive uh i was alive though
um let's take a look at it i didn't mean
to start at the beginning but going all
the way forward
we see that we're gonna end up in a
similar position
um after
one more move
see that kramnik was organizing around
this pawn lekko had had enough of that
pawn sacrifices his uh exchange and we
end up in this end game so this is
actually a much better version of the
rooks versus queen end game for white
than we actually see in the yawn magnus
game now saving grace for yon he still
has a bishop so it's not quite this
simplified
but we're gonna see that even when you
just have three versus three on the
king's side life can be really really
difficult for the queen the rooks can
organize attack weaknesses and the queen
is simply not enough to keep these
pieces defended
so really quickly i just want to show
you what happens
first of all black can easily pick off
the a4 pawn it's the benefit of just
having two attackers to one defender the
queen is sort of helpless against that
so that pawn's gone but that's fine
um we see that white is uh as expected
trying to make some threats around the
black king but black is able to parry
these
and then
black locks the structure over here
pro making this f2 pawn a more permanent
weakness
there is one moment of tactical uh
importance here that's that queen h6
gets met by rook a6
and this queen is actually totally
trapped so you can't take that pawn on
h6 that's why we see f3
and then slowly but surely kramnik
maneuvers the rooks
and eventually
manages to uh
gets
or sorry kramnik maneuvers the rooks and
manages to get
uh peter lecko stuck here this move rook
2 to a6 is actually
um convincingly winning so to win this
game all kramnik needed to do is win one
of these pawns then he'd be be up a pawn
and rip a6 is actually
making two threats at the same time
so threat number one is to come to a3
adding a second attacker to the f3 pawn
and you see threat number two to add two
attackers to the f3 pawn this one's a
little bit more subtle so rick a3 is the
first idea
and what is black's second idea
to get two attackers there
that's exactly right rook f4 and then
rook f6 so to prevent rook f4
white would need to attack the rook on
a6 to keep this rook from moving to
prevent rook a3 white needs to attack
the a3 square attacking both of those
scores at the same time seems really
really difficult um and queen a4 sadly
not a good move um
so white is sort of out of luck here and
can't defend both goes king g2 but this
does allow rook f4 rook f6
then black just takes this pawn of
course defending with the queen is is
pointless
um up upon in a king and pawn end game
is going to be easily winning for black
so what's the point of showing this game
well the point of this is that it makes
it really really apparent the kind of
danger jan napomnishi is in if things
ever ever ever simplify in yon's
position
where we get either like four versus
four on the on the king's side or even a
little bit more simplified than that
it's not going to be pretty the rooks
are going to easily be able to double
against the f7 pawn and create all all
kinds of threats
i want to show one more example because
i found it very funny so just as i am
referencing leko kramnik
i actually found an annotated version of
this game in a references an older game
between gurgaon izzy and averbach
and in this game
it's even more convincing actually black
was able to to keep track of this pawn
but then white was able to make use of
threats of checkmate around the black
king
to slowly bring the king forward
and then eventually trade into a winning
king and pawn end game with rook to h7
so this
i i like even better as an example
because it highlights that the rooks can
make some serious checkmating threats
against the king now i don't want to
spend too much time here because we have
a lot more ground to cover in our actual
game but again this historical context
understanding uh past games that are
similar to your current position uh
really helps you in decision making
processes in the decision-making process
so
what's the point the point is that if
given the opportunity magnus will gladly
trade this night for this bishop and
have a very good chance to win the end
game even if it's objectively drawn for
example that leko kramnik game
objectively that should be a draw but
when it happens over the board uh quite
often you're seeing that the side with
the rooks uh is able to win using these
these various threats
so just want to highlight yon is in a
lot of danger here which is why he needs
to be very accurate and why he ran into
a little bit of trouble in the game
uh so at this point obviously magnus is
in quite a bit of time pressure
and jan is trying to uh
both pressure magnus on the clock
and um not go too far down on the clock
himself and so bishop b2 is played in
the game this turns out to actually be a
pretty serious mistake uh jan needed to
go with queen b3 right away to apply
this kind of pressure but understandably
what turned yon away from this idea well
he didn't want to allow knight takes e5
f takes d5 and something like this
because we've seen just how dangerous
the rooks can be it's actually very very
difficult for black to fully uh
save the game here you have to calculate
very very accurately because otherwise
you do end up getting trackmated for
example queen takes b4
is actually losing the game if i
remember correctly like something like
check
again cheating with the engine here just
to show the idea
g4 i think is the idea yeah g4
and somehow someway
black is getting into quite a bit of
trouble
yeah rook hg7 like obviously not a lot
of time on the clock these things are
going to be difficult to see
but the point is that black is is
getting into a lot of danger here like
queen e1 this is like plus six
and yeah okay the h pawn is also going
to be good enough to to tell the tale
but that just shows you how easily you
can go wrong like queen takes b4 why
would you not capture this pawn
turns out black needs to make use of
threats over here and queen e2 to help
defend his h5 pawn and that's the way
that he can sort of balance the game
now that's a lot to ask of somebody with
20 minutes on the clock against somebody
with three minutes on the clock
uh and keep in mind there's no increment
at this point so i wanted to highlight
that while the majority of the mistakes
this game are made in the next few moves
it's under sort of
enormously difficult circumstances it's
the world championship low time on the
clock and very very precise calculation
is needed in these end games
so that helps us understand right uh jan
is aware of these games where the two
rooks beat the queen magnus is aware of
the games with the two rooks beat the
queen so queen b3 is not high on your
list of things that that you really want
to be doing so bishop b2 trying to keep
the bishop alive or if you take with the
rook at least getting a much better
version here right we can uh take on d3
and the rooks are far much further away
from check meeting the black king than
than otherwise
so bishop b2 is the idea magnus finds
the correct rook to c5 queen to d6 and
then again this is where magnus misses
his fantastic opportunity to to win the
game in style
but once again it's going to be
requiring sort of absurdly accurate uh
calculation abilities three minutes on
the clock he couldn't find it uh as you
all probably know roxy to c2 is winning
and again this goes back to threats
around the black king just to show you
the line and sort of show you how
difficult it can be uh takes on a3
knight f4 is the idea i'm sure magnus
got this far but after queen to f8 it's
actually a very very narrow uh line for
magnus to walk here you go rook c7
um
rook d to c7 introducing this threat
take on b4 you check check a lot of
these are only moves by the way bring
the other rook in knight back to f4
and then the idea
by the way g4 is very important the idea
is you can sacrifice all manner of
things because you're able to use your
h-pawn to promote
and just to show you how the line ends
white picks up a bishop on a3 and is
gonna be up a rook so
you know points to you if you're able to
calculate all of that in three minutes
uh you would be better at calculating
than than magnus carlsen
um so magnus understandably didn't see
all that went for slightly safer options
with rook to d1
we see some simplifications
and now jan goes a little bit crazy so
he's trying to pressure magnus on the
clock they have five moves to make
before the time control
but i really don't understand why he's
not capturing on b4 doesn't make a lot
of sense to me make use of this pin
take this pawn while you can
because otherwise you might end up in in
serious trouble now what he might have
been worried about is allowing this
knight to f4 with complications that
we've we've sort of seen before
um so he plays this move e5 which i
think is you know fair enough that's a
good start
magnus plays rook to c2
and now queen to d5 and this really is
is the mistake so
uh you know e5 fair enough you want to
take away the f4 square before capturing
on b4 to stop knight f4 but here it
really is time to take this pawn you
need to capture this pawn to make sure
you're not going to be any worse
instead he chooses this move queen to d5
magnus realizes that rook d1 was a
little bit dumb and puts his rook back
on a square where it's defended but now
of course
you can no longer take this pawn right
this knight's no longer pinned to the
rook on on d1 and magnus is again going
to be in good practical position this
game now that the computer is still
giving
zeroes here but understanding what we
know about about this end game
historically and practically it's going
to be very difficult for black to keep
everything under control
okay
continuing on here i think my laptop
might be
dying here
all right you're good
okay they can hear me all right sorry
guys more technical issues it's all my
fault um but we're back in action now
and i was just saying as so often
happens in chess magnus makes a mistake
on the 40th move here so see if you're
able to find the the winning move here
for magnus carlsen
and again
it's it has to do with this idea that
the queen is not going to be able to
survive in the long run uh practically
at least
against these two rooks
so just taking on e4 is what magnus did
in the game uh and the problem here is
that life would be great if black would
simply take us and then we get this end
game that we want but black is not going
to take the knight after knight e4
so yeah um
the live audience good enough to be
magnus not good enough to be stockfish
it's tough
what about taking on a4 taking an a4 is
great except again black's not going to
take your knight
um and actually no black might take your
knight here um and how are you actually
picking up this bishop because okay well
that hangs a rook
and
otherwise i'm gonna bring my queen
so notably black's pieces are really
awkwardly placed here and so we don't
necessarily have to do something
immediately
so i like the idea of knight to a4 but
the problem is you don't have rook d3 in
the ends to capture the the bishop so
there's an improvement on this idea of
knight a4
any ideas
before i show it
all right let's just show it then it's
rook to c2 um it's a very subtle move
but once you see the move it's not so
hard to understand basically none of
these pieces can move and so
uh
white plays this one move and then is
able to take on a4 and then is able to
come with rook c3 and get this end game
we have so desperately been seeking
um so rook d to c2 that was was the nice
move that would have let magnus have a
much much easier time in this end game
instead knight to e4
and we are in for the long haul black
manages to keep this pawn on a4
and it's it's gonna be quite a fight
here
so in the game we see magnus organizing
the pieces gets this knight to f4
playing a little bit of pressure here
but the problem now for white is you can
never fully commit yourself to attacking
this king because this pawn is queening
so so quickly and because of that black
should be able to survive the end game
now now obviously that's not quite what
happened
so we're gonna skip forward a few moves
um okay so we end up in this position
right
magnus has actually come up with a
really uh nice plan to try and get rid
of this pawn on a3
so just as with two rooks versus the
queen two rooks and a knight versus a
queen in the bishop uh white has one
advantage uh just inherently and that's
that he has three attackers to two
defenders right black simply only has
two pieces
so magnus's point is that he wants to go
knight c2 and just take this pawn on a3
he's organized his pieces yes these
rooks are are fairly passive but they
needed to be in order to both defend the
king and attack this pawn
now the problem that he has is black has
a really great idea here of doing
nothing so king to h7 king h2
and then here
if black bites his time with something
like king to g6 doesn't touch these
pieces then white's gonna be in for a
really difficult time trying to uh
trying to to make progress if you
continue now with the plan of knight to
c2 your plan sort of fails at the final
step because bishop to e5 is a really
nice move for black you don't have time
to take on a3 because this rook is
attacked on a1 and if you move the rook
out of the way
black is happy to repeat
and if you try again
i'll go i'll come to e5 again
if you come back to d4 i can just come
back to d6 simply and you can just never
really find your way to to capture this
pawn comfortably so
because of that i think if king g6 were
to be played magnus would have to take
his time and find some other way to
activate the rooks try to get them
behind the pawn and we would be in for
another long fight
instead jan goes for this move queen to
e4
and uh this is going to give magnus a
great opportunity here he actually just
captures on a3
and now just as with the two rooks
versus the queen
an end game like this is also not going
to be comfortable for black
these pawns are simply so weak that even
with just a rook and a knight versus a
queen max is going to be be able to pick
up those pawns eventually he's going to
be able to pick off those pawns sort of
one by one
and use his own pawns to to try to win
and we're going to get something very
similar to what happened in the game
instead yon was able to keep the game
going with queen day takes h4
king to g1
and now white's rook is attacked so
uh uh black has has a tempo here after
queen to e4 black's queen is also
attacked
uh and the last thing i want to uh to
mention in reference to sort of
historical games is this game between
georgiev and mizitz uh mises from
actually this year the 2021 grand swiss
so
jan goes for queen e4 in the game it
actually has a pretty interesting option
to try and capture on g3
with the idea being that he's hoping he
can eventually pick up
the pawn on on e3 as well and actually
the better version of this would be
something like queen g4 first and then
bishop takes g3
and just bear with me here let's say it
works something like this
and so this seems like a really unusual
end game uh but it turns out
that white is
probably
uh winning in this endgame as well
and how can you possibly know that well
if you keep up with chess you you follow
a lot of the interesting games going on
then you might have seen this game
between uh cruel georgiev and norman's
mises
and what happened in this game
is believe it or not
almost this exact end game we have two
rooks in a night against a queen and a
bunch of pawns and even though the
computer at the beginning of this end
game is like yeah the queen's doing fine
uh one by one
uh white was actually able to pick up
these pawns here coordinating the pieces
and
next the b pawn falls
knight takes pawn
and then even these king side pawns that
are connected white is able to slowly
but surely
press forward
and
win
so he wins all the pawns
and then actually these end games with
the queen versus two rooks in the night
uh with no pawns on the board tend to be
winning for white given any big
exceptions just to show you how that
happens
just like with the pawns white finds a
way to escape from checks and then walks
the king down the board
and eventually
the end is near and checkmate is is
coming quite quickly so
crazy end games right but just by
following chess you start to build up
this knowledge of the different things
uh and that helps you make decisions in
your own games so
just goes to show you why these players
are avoiding certain end games why
they're going for certain end games they
follow chess they know these things and
that is the huge benefit that you can
have in your own chess games
when you follow chess when you watch
commentary like this you get exposed to
these amazing ideas
uh and you can learn from them to make
decisions in your own games so
that didn't happen in the game and we
actually have like 70 more moves to go
but i'm just gonna sort of zoom through
them here
basically what happens now is we see
magnus trying to organize his pieces
against these weaknesses
all while avoiding various checks now
black tries to keep white pen down to
this e3 pawn
magnus tries to shuffle around with the
rooks to find the perfect moment to win
one of these pawns
in the game that moment finally is
arriving
we see one or two more repetitions and
then finally rook takes f5 the first
pawn falls
now perhaps uh
you know jan could have could have held
on a little bit better but
more or less i think this end game was
going to be inevitable so we see rook
takes f7 in this case and magnus again
transposes into a similar endgame to
what we were just looking at and
unfortunately i couldn't find too much
historical precedent for this exact end
game with the rook in the night against
the queen with some extra pawns
but uh now there is one it's called the
2021 world championship
and from here on out i'm not gonna delve
into the crazy analysis of this end game
because it's very much specific based in
calculation and sort of inhuman at times
basically white is going to try to keep
his king sheltered by these pawns and
very slowly but surely advance them up
the board until he's able to win so just
zooming through the moves again
i'm not here to give you the details on
what's coming on here going on here
but eventually magnus finds a nice
little formation to avoid checks
um takes him a while
but you see here he brings the knight
back to g1 and then with the queen
checking from the left he first puts
this rook on d4 blocking checks from the
diagonal then this knight in e2 blocking
checks from the side and once he's done
that he can successfully push this pawn
forward to e4 and step by step like this
he continues pushing forward we see
checks
jan eventually does play h4 trying to
trade these pawns and i think this is a
good idea it helps
remove some of that shelter for the
white king
and so we continue onwards
and eventually
we see
the rook in front of the pawns e5 gets
played queen a2 king h3 and this is the
quote-unquote losing move for yon
it turns out for whatever reason and i
don't think yawn could have been
expected to know this
um the drawing idea essentially revolves
around making sure this knight can't get
to h5 once this knight lands on h5 the
white king has enough shelter up the
board to to win the game and my
my brief summary of what's going on here
is at the beginning of the end game the
white king was safe on these squares
because the pawns were on this half of
the board providing some shelter
now that the pawns have advanced the
white king actually needs to come up
here to have enough shelter to escape
checks from the queen
and so to facilitate that we need this
knight in h5 so that we can walk our
king up the board hide behind the knight
and now we're in good position to
advance the pawns while still having
having shelter
so the the drawing moves here are queen
b1 or queen c2
what do those have in common well they
target this rook to prevent knight h5
white tries to solve that only drawing
move is queen d1 again just trying to
stop knight h5 if you try king h4
again going for knight h5 only drawing
move is queen e1 pinning the knight to
stop this move try king g4 i need to go
either check or queen g1
again stopping knight h5 and that seems
to be the drawing idea white can never
comfortably get this knight to h5 and
the black queen is able to uh tactically
prevent it at every turn and that's why
the end game is a draw
now
i would never find this idea and jan was
not able to find the idea he goes queen
e6 instead but now this is in fact
losing because we get our knight to h5
by force
and then the rest is is sort of history
uh yan could have made life very very
difficult for magnus by going queen to
a2 here
when it takes white a full 30 moves
according to the table base before he
can advance one of his pawns but
theoretically should be winning with
knight h5
in the game though the game ended a lot
more quickly with magnus taking
advantage of certain tactics
to push the pawn gets rook f7
again takes here is actually losing
to a king and pawn end game of all
things
with a victory
uh so king d8 instead and now f5 and now
again we're gonna see this idea after
knight g7 the white king has shelter
um
on the other side of the board finally
and that's why it was so important to
get the knight the night forward
and so start to finish that is the
longest uh game ever played in a world
championship match and that's my
explanation of what was going on sort of
at every turn
so any final questions for me before i
turn it over to our wonderful
grandmaster in residence for the next
hour
any questions at all i know this is a
behemoth of a game and there was a lot
that we talked about but the the main
point i want to take away is how useful
it is to have those historical games to
have that knowledge and how you can use
it to make decisions and how these
players did use it to make their
decisions in in this game
all right well with that thank you all
so much for watching i don't want to
take up any more time because we have uh
former us champion alex shabalov here to
delve into some more end games and talk
about fortresses which yon was not able
to find so that's all i have for you
today thank you so much for watching as
always my name is caleb denby and i will
see you next time
[Music]
you